la circonscription de
berthier-maskinongé serait-elle en t en
tout cas les candidats fantômes si ça en
télé
venu après l'épisode de ruth ellen
brosseau en 2011 micheline c'est au tour
de la fille d'elizabeth may de
solliciter les appuis sans trop faire
campagne et détails avec marie-eve
cousineau il n'y a pas de pancartes
électorales du parti vert dans berthier
maskinongé est pourtant une candidate
verte présente après la néo démocrate
ruth ellen brosseau en 2011 c'est au
tour de la fille d'elizabeth may de se
présenter dans la circonscription sans y
faire campagne
kate middleton n'a pas l'intention d'y
mettre les pieds et la compagne sa mère
durant toute la campagne électorale pour
ainsi nécessaire d'avoir quelqu'un
proche est quelqu'un qui peut l'appuyer
en tout temps alors je n'ai pas vraiment
le choix
mais même si j'aimerais bien connaître
les gens pour qui je suis candidat ruth
ellen brosseau a été élu avec plus de
5000 voix de majorité lors de la vague
orange
en 2011 les électeurs de
berthier-maskinongé pourrait-il voter de
nouveau pour un candidat fantôme
les principaux partis présentent tous
des candidats dans berthier maskinongé
qui est mais brune reconnaît d'ailleurs
que ses chances de l'emporter sont
limitées d'autant qu'elle est la seule
candidate fantôme